il est devenu le chevalier anti wok qui
mène une croisade pour les ultras
conservateurs au pays depuis son
éclatante réélection en tant que
gouverne de sentis signe des lois à la
vitesse de l'éclair aussi controversé
les unes que les autres
mais dans la petite vanne à Miami c'est
mythique joueur de Domino il préfère
encore un certain dans notre chambre
non non pas des synthis je préfère dans
notre chambre dit-il
et
beaucoup mieux dit celui-ci sur les
questions d'immigration et pour
l'économie
car la nouvelle loi de scintille sur
l'immigration clandestine criminalise
non seulement les migrants sans papiers
mais ceux qui les transportent dans leur
véhicule ou encore ceux qui les emploie
Elina Santana est une avocate
spécialisée sur les questions
d'immigration
40% des travailleurs agricoles sont sans
papier dit-elle sans compter ceux qui
travaillent dans la construction la
restauration les hôtels
la Floride version 210 donne un
avant-goût de sa vision au niveau
national pour la droite conservatrice
et puis il y a cette fameuse censure
qu'il appuie de livre jugés obscène ou
inappropriée dans les établissements
scolaires
sur la tablette les livres qui sont
bannis dans un district scolaire en
Floride
c'est que les livres visaient ont des
histoires sur la communauté LGBTQ
encore sur tout ce qui touche le racisme
c'est à peine saccola port maritime dans
le nord-ouest de la Floride aux portes
de l'Alabama que se joue donc la
bataille judiciaire sur la liberté
d'expression
auteur parents maison d'édition contre
le district scolaire du comté des
scambia
une enseignante de ce district avec
l'aval du conseil d'administration a
fait retirer de la bibliothèque scolaire
une centaine de livres jugés
inappropriés elle n'a pas répondu à nos
demandes d'entrevue
son pornographiques dit-elle ce sont de
mauvais livres on a demandé de les
retirer
on ne peut même pas répéter les mots
qu'il y a dedans dit-elle tellement
c'est inappropriés
[Musique]
une guerre de culture dans le Sunshine
State qui ne semble pas perturber le
marché de Penza Cola ici on vote surtout
républicain on hésite entre dans notre
chambre et de Santis les déboires
judiciaires du district scolaire ne
retiennent pas trop la tension
à part celle de Charles douter
Dieu a créé l'homme et la femme dit-il
et non choisi ton genre
c'est Dieu
nous sommes donc allés voir la maison de
Dieu
brunch et pasteur à cette église
méthodiste
Dieu ne nous a pas créé blanc noir
binaire dit-il nous sommes de toutes les
couleurs entre les deux
sont prêtes dans ce qu'ils appellent le
sanctuaire dans une heure la salle sera
comble pour un mariage
c'est un pas de bannir un livre dit-il
il en suffit d'un autre pour qu'il
commence à bannir les gens que ces
livres représentent
je rentre dans le moule je suis un homme
blanc hétérodite-t-il je représente ce
que la société aime mais il y a des
enfants des jeunes qui ne rentrent pas
dans ce moule
[Musique]
nuances Émilie qui crée un retour en
arrière avec loin de Saintes à la tête
du pays
sous sa gouverne l'avortement est
désormais interdit en Floride après six
semaines de grossesse et plus besoin non
plus d'avoir un permis pour porter une
arme
de Santis seraient-il l'homme de leur
pour la droite
c'est un très bon gouverneur très
conservateur dit-il mais il n'est pas à
la hauteur de Donald Trump
il a été admirable durant la pandémie
c'est donc le duel entre dans notre
champ et son ancien protégé loin de
saint-is mais est-ce que le fils va
réussir à tuer le père ici Radio-Canada